hey everyone
welcome to simply learn's youtube
channel
in terms of programming java is a very
vast subject
there are high chances that a beginner
couldn't always cover
every topic for an interview but what if
you can stay
on the safer side with the most
frequently asked top 10 questions
that could always back you up this video
from simply learn is about the same
here we will discuss the top 10 tricky
and
most frequently asked java interview
questions
so before we begin make sure that you
have subscribed to our youtube channel
and hit that bell icon
to never miss an update from simply
learn now without further ado
let's get started with the top 10 java
interview questions
so the top 10th question in our list for
today is
what is multithreading so the answer for
this question
is multi-threading is a procedure of
executing
two or more threads simultaneously to
perform a certain operation via
utilizing the cpu resources
to the maximum multiple threads do not
need
separate memory allocation for each one
of them so
by this way they also save time and
memory
and run in parallel to each other so
followed by the 10 question
let us move on to the top ninth question
does java include pointers now this
question is most frequently asked
amongst many interviews for the
beginners
so basically java has java virtual
machine
so in that instance we have some
advantages and we might not need
point is exactly there now let's look
into the answer
so java includes java virtual machine
which automatically takes care of memory
allocations
so we do not find any use of pointers in
real-time programming
in java and also java has its own
garbage collector to free the unused
memory as well
moving on to the next question
what are jdk jvm and jre
this is also one of the commonly asked
questions now let us discuss the full
forms of jdk
jvm and gre and also what are their
functionalities
so jdk stands for java development
kit so this is the package which you
download for your jvm
and jre together so when you download
jdk from the official oracle website you
will be getting the packages of jvm and
jre together
and you need to download them and later
install them after installing jdk you
need to set the path
for jvm and gre together
more about that and how to install java
in your windows system
and the link to the video is added in
the description box below kindly check
it
now moving on to the next one which is
jbm so jvm stands for
java virtual machine so this is the tool
that is mainly responsible to convert
your
program into byte code so basically when
you run a java code
the compiler will not directly run your
code first
it will convert the entire program
directly into the bytecode
and that particular bytecode is run by
the compiler
this is the main reason why java is
being
platform independent so moving on to the
next one that is
gre jre stands for java
runtime environment so java runtime
environment
is the one which is responsible to
provide you all the class libraries and
resources for the code execution now
moving on to the next question
what is the difference between
overloading and overriding
so by now i suppose most of you have
been facing this question in many
interviews
so the fundamental difference between
the overloading and overriding
is as follows when you have two or more
methods in the same class
with the same name but different
parameters
parameters in the sense the number of
values you pass to your function call
for example
let us imagine that we have two
functions by the name
add and the function that they will be
performing as edition
so one method will be having two
variables
for example add int a into b
so you are sending two values to the
function and another function with the
same name that is add
will have three values that is adding
x into y and set so here we have
different parameters but with the same
function call
this type of scenario is called as
overloading
in java now let us discuss about
overriding
in java when the method signature has
same name
and same number of parameters in both
super class
and child class then it is called as
overriding
now let us imagine that we have the same
method let us add
int a into b in both super class
and child class now super class is
something which has
highest priority let us imagine that we
have to call a method
from child class so based on the
priority of the function call
the jvm might call the method from child
class
ignoring the super class so this is
where a method got
overridden by the priorities so this
particular act
is called as function overriding or
method overriding
in java now moving forward we have our
next question
what is package in java remember that
whenever you write a code in java you
need
a package so especially when you're
working on a high-end ide like
eclipse you need to define the package
first
it is possible that for some minor
programs which you can run on
command prompt you don't need a package
but it is a good habit to use a package
so here the question is what exactly is
a package
a package in java is a namespace that
organizes a set of related classes and
interfaces
conceptually you can think of packages
as being a similar version of your
folders in your computer
now moving on to the next question
which is the base class of all the
exceptions in java
or you can also consider this question
as which is the library that is
responsible for
all the exceptions in java so the answer
for this question is the parent class
or the base class for all the exceptions
in java
as java.lang library
now the next question if i import a
package
will the jvm import all the sub packages
of the imported package
now let us imagine that you're working
on a package called
x and you needed something from a
different package
let us imagine that package is eight so
that package has already imported
few more packages like pc and d so let
us imagine
again you have a package that you are
currently working on that is x
and you needed something from a
different package that is a
so a has already imported package b
packet c
and package t so if you now import
package
a into package x then do you have the
possibilities that
you also import package b c d
along with a so the answer for this
question
is no when you import a specific package
then the sub packages of this thing will
not be imported
here in the scenario if you wanted to
include package a into package x then
you can do it
but the packages that a already included
in itself that is
b c and d will not be imported into x
however the developer can manually
import the sub packages
when fines necessary so if the developer
needs the
sub packages that is bc and d he can
manually import it into x
but they will not come automatically
when you import
a into x now moving ahead into our next
question
does java has go to statement so goto is
something we can face in
some programming languages like c now
does java also support that the answer
for this question
is no java does not have goto statement
but it has something similar called
labels so labels are used to change the
flow of a program and gem
to a specific instruction and label is
based on a condition
now moving ahead into our next question
is it possible to have a class compiled
without
main method yes so the main method is
always the starting point for compiling
for a compiler or an interpreter but can
you compile
a complete class without a main method
so this is one of the frequently asked
questions so
in java it is possible
you can execute a java program without a
main method by using static block
static block in java is a group of
statements that gets executed
only once when the class is loaded into
the memory
by java class loader it is also known as
static initialization block
now the last question in our list
can a dead thread be restarted in java's
multi-threading so there are chances
that sometimes you need to kill a thread
so sometimes after you kill a thread you
feel that that thread
might be important for your program so
is it kind of possible to restart it
again
the answer for this question is no
once a thread is terminated in java we
cannot restart it
now with that we have come to an end of
this top 10 interview questions in
java if you have any queries regarding
the questions
discussed in this tutorial or if you
feel that we have missed out anything
important
then please feel free to let us know in
the comment sections below until next
time
thank you stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here